[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHIU-KI CHAN: Welcome.
My name is Chiu-Ki
Chan, and today we
are going to talk about
Advanced Android Espresso.
In case you do
not know, Espresso
is a testing framework.
So let me just back up a
little bit and ask all of you,
how many of you do
Android testing?
Oh.
OK.
More than half.
That's excellent.
And how many of you have
written Espresso tests?
Little bit less than a half.
So cool.
So this is Advanced
Android Espresso,
so I'll be going through the
beginning stuff pretty quickly.
But hopefully, for those of you
who have not done it before,
you'll still get a
good enough overview
so then when I explain more
advanced techniques you
can follow along.
Well first, what is Espresso?
In short, Espresso is an
automated UI testing framework,
meaning that you write
some code and then
you can let go of your
hand, because Espresso
will click buttons and type
text and do all these user
actions for you, and then you
can verify the state of the app
to make sure that's behaving
the way you expect it to behave.
And what's nice about Espresso
is that, well, first of all,
it's a first party library.
It is written by
people at Google.
It gets delivered through
the Android Testing Support
Library.
And like I said, it simulates
user action, so people--
not people, I guess--
the program's actually
cutting the button and
exercising your app that way.
But the most interesting
thing about Espresso
is that it does automatic
synchronization.
That sounds really fancy,
and whatever that means.
So I can tell you what happened
before Espresso came along.
Before Espresso
came along, there
is already a way to do all these
things, like click on buttons
and verify.
But the problem is that
the click action that
comes from your test
app is not synchronized
with your main app.
Meaning that your app
may or may not be ready.
So for us human, it's
instantaneous, right?
Like, you open the app
and the buttons are there.
But it actually takes a
few hundred milliseconds
for the rendering to happen.
And your test thread
is super fast.
So when I was running tests
with my Espresso, what
would happen is that I would
say, go click the button.
And my test code was, like,
there's no button to click.
And that's not because
there's no button.
It is because I was too fast.
So that's all I mean
by synchronization,
is that Espresso
actually have watches.
It will watch over the
UI thread and make sure
that it's idle-- it's
done rendering before it
goes try to click a button.
I mean, it also watches
the AsyncTask thread pool,
so if you are doing something in
the background with AsyncTask,
it will wait for that as well.
So that's what's nice about
automatic synchronization.
Another way to
put it is, I don't
know if you have
written tests before,
and you have to make it
sleep to make it pass.
To do the synchronization.
I mean, I make it
sound like magic,
but actually, behind the scenes,
that's what Espresso does.
But it sleeps for you.
It's not-- this doesn't
blindly sleep for, like,
500 milliseconds.
It's like, sleep, and wake
up and say, hey, UI thread,
are you done?
Oh, you're not done.
Oh, OK, I'll sleep again.
So it makes it a little
more intelligent, sleeping,
so that you don't have
to worry about it.
So behind the scenes, there's
still some sleeping going on,
but at least you are
not the one that's
randomly guessing some
random number of milliseconds
to sleep.
So I'm going to go through
Halliwell, for those of you who
have not done this before.
Espresso kind of
have a formula--
that is, I think what
people call a Fluent API,
so there's three parts to this--
onView, Perform, and Check.
onView is the way to
find a view on your app.
So for instance, while we
have this Halliwell app,
we have this button
called Greet.
To look for this button, we
can use the withid function,
and we can give it the ID that
says look for the greet button.
OK?
So now, at this point we
have located the button.
Now we need to do
something to it.
With that, it's viewAction.
We can ask Espresso to
then click on this button,
and afterwards, we'll
verify something.
In our case, for some reason,
you can only Greet once.
Once you Greet, the
button will be disabled.
So once I click on the Greet
button, I want to check that.
It says, check
matches not enabled.
So in Espresso, you can also
combine different viewActions
and reassertions.
So in this case, there's
a built-in function
called "it's enabled,"
that I can use to verify
that the button is enabled.
There's no function
called "it's not enabled."
What you do is, you negate that.
And I have actually published
this on the GitHub repository,
and like I said, the whole
slide deck is already shared.
If you go on Twitter,
you can click through
and find all these examples.
There are a lot more coming.
So don't frantically
write down URLs.
That is just not the best
use of your time right now.
So like I said a
little bit earlier,
the withid is something
that Espresso provides
for you to look for a view.
There are other things,
like click, matches,
and it's enabled, so almost
everything here is coming out
of the Espresso library.
But the "not" part
is from Hamcrest.
It's still bundled with
the Espresso Library,
but it's not written
by the folks at Google.
It's a Java-specific
library that you
can do different things.
So these are all the Espresso
viewMatches, viewActions,
viewAssertions, and we are
going to sit here the whole talk
to go through each one
of them, and then--
until you fall asleep.
No, no, that's not the agenda.
I'm just going to show you this
because that's a cheat sheet
online that you can go check
if you are wondering what
is the capability of Espresso.
On top of that, like I mentioned
earlier, there's Hamcrest.
Again, cheat sheets.
Function galore.
I'm not going to go through
that, but you can go
and you can take a quick look.
And there's things like
what I did already--
"not" is one of it,
and then you can also
do other things that is an
instance of, so basically
Java-level matching, rather
than Android matching.
So with this, you can
actually combine them,
and it's going to become
much more powerful
and stuff than
just a single one.
Let's go through one example.
Suppose I have an app
that uses the Toolbar.
I mean, you have an app that
uses the Toolbar, right?
Did you supply the
layout to the Toolbar?
No.
So we are not going to
be able to use withid
to find the Toolbar, to
verify what the title is.
So what are we going to
do if we want to verify
that I set the title properly?
Well, we're going to bust
our Hierarchy Viewer.
How many of you have
used Hierarchy Viewer?
Great.
What this is, is
you can take a look
at not just the part
of the UI that you
set-- so sometimes when
you run an activity,
you do set contentView.
And then you're given
Layout, and that's the part
that you designed.
It actually shows the whole
UI that's being rendered.
So you can see things that
are beyond your control.
In our case, we can see that
there is the TextView, which
has my awesome title
in it, and that's
the view that we want to verify.
But the problem is, this
guy doesn't have an ID.
So how are we going
to look for it?
Well, fortunately,
we can see that this
is a child of a class that
is of the type Toolbar.
So we can combine matches
to pinpoint this view.
Let's see how we are
going to do this.
Well, first of all, I have
a helper function that
help me find the Toolbar title.
And the reason why I have
this helper function that
match Toolbar title
is because that way,
I can reuse it, right?
If I have multiple tasks that I
want to find the Toolbar title
and match it, I just
need to write it once.
So here is half the magic,
where alloff, that's
the Hamcrest matcher.
And then I will
look for something
that isAssignableFrom
TextView meaning I'm
looking for a class that
is a TextView, or a child
of TextView, like, maybe it's
a button, but in our case,
it's a TextView.
And then, because
we have an all of,
so we have to satisfy
two conditions.
The first condition is the
view itself is a TextView.
The second condition
is that that view also
has a parent that
is of type Toolbar.
So we are trying to translate
what we see in Hierarchy Viewer
into the matches.
So with all that, we will
find that particular TextView,
and then we can go ahead
and do the match with text,
so that we can verify that
the Toolbar is displaying
what we expect it to display.
So far so good?
OK, good.
Exercise this much of your body.
But even though there's
a lot of matches
and you can combine
them, there are
times that we want to
write a custom matcher.
In fact, we're going
to change this code
to use a custom matcher.
And it's not just
for demoing purposes.
The reason why I
want to change it
is because, when you're doing
that check that I showed you,
that you use the Hierarchy
Viewer to look deep
into a view, it may change.
Right?
This is not your code.
This is probably
the Support Library,
if you are using
App Compat, right?
Today, the Toolbar display it
by having one single layer,
so you can use it with
parent to pinpoint your view.
Tomorrow things may change.
It may get nested
inside linear layout,
because-- well, they don't
have to explain to you why,
they just want to do it, right?
So to protect yourself
from those changes,
it's much better to use
a published API, right?
Because when you are sneaking
into their viewHeirarchy,
that's not part
of the public API,
and they allowed to change it.
Whereas, for example, here,
we are actually going to use
the toolbar.getTitle() function.
That is a part of the public
API of the Toolbar object.
So instead of using all those
matched parents, and alloff,
and whatnot, what
we're going to do is,
this one is very similar.
So on the-- well, this is
actually just a function--
ViewToolbarTitle.
But what we have is that I have
written a custom thing called
withToolbarTitle.
This is the dense code coming.
Can everybody see it?
OK, that's good.
So what we have
here is something
called BoundedMatcher.
This is, again-- I think
it's actually Hamcrest.
What happened here
is that I'm saying
that I want a
viewMatcher that is
specific to a Toolbar-- which
is why there's a generic that I
pass into Toolbar class.
And when I want to see
whether this matches safely,
I will go ahead and
call the Toolbar, which
is passed in to me in
this function because
of this generic, and I'll
call the functions GetTitle,
and then I will match
it with the TextMatcher.
So TextMatcher, if you can
see here, is of Matcher Class.
So the previous slide--
the if-- that's the-- this
is kind of confusing-- "if."
That's the Matcher.
So we're passing a
TextMatcher, and the reason
why I did it this way
is because you can also
pass in a different Matcher,
so you can also do something
like "starts with,"
"ends with," "contains"--
so it's much more powerful
than if you're just
passing a string.
So those are all, again,
Hamcrest Matchers.
You don't actually have to write
what the function starts with.
You can just pass it in.
So with this, since I just swap
it in to my helper function,
then I'm done, right?
All the code I'm trying to
verify the Toolbar title will
now use get.Title() function.
So this is how you
write a custom matcher.
Well, this is [INAUDIBLE]
case, because what I want to do
is, I want to verify
the Toolbar object.
So by giving it as a
generic, I can have access
to the function.
So I can verify.
So I've also written matches,
for example, that I can verify
the text color of a TextView.
So if I [INAUDIBLE]
Espresso, you
can do the WithText to find
out what is printed out,
but I want to know
what color it is.
TextView provides that.
You can use the-- you can ask
it to get you the current color.
All right?
So, OK, then wrap it
inside a BoundedMatcher
and then in the
matchbase function,
called the
getCurrentColor function.
Yes.
I already covered that.
Again, that's the full example
that even the blog post,
if you want to read again what,
actually, what I just said.
But if you want to
read it in prose,
you can go ahead and do that.
Now, something more interesting.
onData-- has anyone
used this matcher?
What does this do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHIU-KI CHAN: You
are half right.
It checks the List View,
but not Recycler View.
So we'll get to that.
So, yeah, so onData allows
you to check on the List View.
So for those of you
who have not written it
before, you may
be wondering, why
do you need a different thing?
So the problem with-- what
the problem is, the way List
View is done is that the views
comes in and out as you scroll,
because it's using
the same views,
but just swapping in
new data to the space.
So you cannot just say. oh, I'm
going to look for the view with
ID list items.
That is not going to work.
So the formula for using onData
is similar to the onView,
if you compare it side by side.
Except you have some extra
things, like CallDataOption.
We're going to
get to an example,
and it's much easier
to understand.
So one next thing is,
instead of a ViewMatcher,
you have an ObjectMatcher.
So the way onData
works is that it
will, instead of
look for a view,
it will look into the data.
Essentially you're
already-- for example,
if you're displaying
an array of strings,
it will look for strings rather
than views, like TextViews.
And the Data Options--
I hope you can see it--
is things like in AdaptAView.
So for example, even if
you just-- if you just
look [INAUDIBLE] on
the data, but you
have multiple AdaptAView,
multiple ListViews in your app,
then it doesn't know which
one you're trying to match.
So you can give it a Matcher,
so this time you can do,
for example, in onData view
with ID list-- [INAUDIBLE].list.
And you can also do
things like onChildView.
So maybe you pinpoint
that particular list item,
but then it has two TextViews,
and an ImageView inside,
so you can use
onChildView with ID,
or the id.image, or
something like that,
to do further Matching.
Here's an example.
I have a pretty
benign-looking ListView.
And what I'm going to do is that
I'm going to look for item 27,
and verify that it says 27.
So right off the bat,
that's a problem, right?
I can't see item 27.
But the beauty of onData is
that it will scroll for you.
So there is yet another reason
why you want to use onData.
Here's a very quick power
play how the app is set up.
I have a array that is the
data-- that is a type item.
Besides, I made 30 of them,
and I iterate it, fill it in,
and I use that to
initialize my List adaptor.
And the item is pretty simple.
It has an integer, and then
when it needs to be displayed,
it displays the
value of the integer.
So now, when-- this is, I
guess, more complicated than I
initially said.
So that's also an
onClick listeners.
When I click on an item, it's
going to display in the footer.
Just because we are
writing a demo app.
So now, we go back
to the test, and say,
let's run a test to verify that.
Before I click on any list item,
the footer is not displayed.
I click on one of
them, and then it
will display with
a matching number.
So that's English, and
translated into Espresso,
I said, before I click
anything, so in the beginning
of the function, I want to
find-- this is the footer
textView, onView with ID
text, check that it matches
that it is not displayed.
OK?
So it's very similar to what we
did earlier of the notEnabled.
Not is enabled.
Next we're going to use the
onData with a value of 27
to pinpoint that
particular item.
In this particular
AdaptAView, in case there
are multiple of them, and
then we perform click on it.
Once we are there, we'll
repeat what we did earlier,
except this time
we actually want
to make sure that it
has the proper text
and it is displayed.
So so far, everything
looks pretty good.
Just one tiny thing. withValue
is not an Espresso function.
You have to write it.
Ah, our best friend
BoundedMatch are here again.
This time, instead of
bounding it to a Toolbar,
we're binding it to a item.
So I pass it in at value
27, that I'm looking for.
And then in
matchSafely, I'm going
to see that it
matches to the item.
So that's what
Espresso goes through.
It looks for an item and
say, hey, are you 27?
Are you 27?
And if it's not, it just keeps
scrolling and keep looking.
Good?
All right.
RecyclerView.
So yeah, I've-- a gentleman
here already mentioned it.
So this RecyclerView will
look pretty much the same
at our ListView.
However, you cannot
use onData with it.
Does anybody know why?
Good.
I'm going to teach
you something.
The reason why you cannot do
it is that RecyclerView is
actually a ViewGroup,
not an AdaptorView.
And even though it looks
surprisingly similar,
under the hood they are
actually very, very different.
So when you're working
with RecyclerView,
you're actually going
to go back to use
onView, instead of onData.
So let's go through an example.
Here is the same "test"
kind of functionally, right?
We verify that the
footer is not displayed,
and then we are going
to click on the item
and then verify
that it's displayed.
However, the meat of it
is completely different.
We start with onView,
with ID RecyclerView.
So after we find the parent.
And then we go ahead and
perform this really, really long
function, which is available
to you in Espresso,
so in the RecyclerView
actions, you
can use these to pinpoint items.
So in our case, we are
calling the one atPosition,
so we say, atPosition
27, click on it.
So that's already
different, right,
because before we were actually
looking inside, and looking
at the item.
There are other things
that you can use.
So instead of using
the position one-- oh.
OK, I'm one slide ahead.
So anyway, this
is the equivalent
of the other-- of
an onData case when
you're using it in a ListView.
Ah, here.
I hope it's not too low.
So besides using
this function, there
are other matches that--
otherView actions that's
provided for you in the
RecyclerView actions.
So instead of
matching the position,
you can also match it
in the Holder position,
or in the item itself,
with a Matcher.
So this gets a
little bit confusing,
because here we are
looking at the position,
but here what we're
doing is still
going through all the views, and
then trying to match the view.
So you'll probably want to
go through the RecyclerView
documentation and
just see what it does.
Again, examples.
I love putting on
examples, because I
want you to go home and actually
download this and muck with it,
and change it a little bit,
like try a different viewAction
and see what happens.
So this is available.
Idling Resource.
Who has used an Idling
Resource before?
Three hands.
OK.
So we are really
getting to the point
where I am showing
you something new.
That's cool.
So Idling Resource.
If you remember, very,
very early in the talk,
when I was telling
you that Espresso
knows to wait for the UI
thread to be idle before it
goes and clicks buttons.
But there are other things
that's happening in the app
that you may want
it to wait as well.
How do you tell Espresso?
Another resource
is the interface
that you need to implement.
And for some reason it's
really confusing to people.
So I have done blog posts on it.
So we're going to go
through one example
in this particular case.
Again, that's what
I said-- Espresso
has a notion of idling, and
these two things are the things
that Espresso is watching for.
We are going to go through an
example where, say you have
an IntentService,
and you want Espresso
to wait until it's done.
So what happens is this.
In your app, you have a button
that says, do something.
And instead of doing
it in the activity,
because it's long
running, it goes off
to ask the
IntentService to do it,
and then the IntentService
has come back and say,
yay, I'm done, and
you can update the UI.
That will stand up.
And this is the code for
the actual Idling Resource.
So it's an interface, and
there are three functions
that you need to override.
The first two are
kind of boilerplate.
It needs to get a
name, because when
you're registering
your resource,
it needs a key, basically, so
that it can keep track of them.
So usually I just
give it a class name.
And then there's this Callback.
You are just dashing away the
Callback that at some point
Espresso will give you
a Callback so that you
can use in this function.
And so ifIdle, now, is the
meat of your IdlingResource.
You are going to-- basically,
Espresso's-- after you register
the IdlingResource, Espresso
is going to come along and say,
hey, are you idle, by calling
the ifIdleNow function,
and you return true or false.
In our particular
case, we are trying
to make sure that the
IntentService is not running.
So in the next slide
that's going to be,
actually,
implementation of this.
But let's say we have these
magic helper functions
that will tell us whether
my IntentService is running
or not.
And I say, if it's not
running, then it's idle.
When it's idle, I can go
ahead and call this Callback
that I stashed away here, so
that I can notify Espresso
and say, it's idle.
Go ahead and do your things.
So that's how IdlingResource
is structured.
But like I said, this is
the magic helper function.
Basically, what we're
doing is that we
are querying the
Activity Manager
for the particular name,
and make sure that the ones
that we are looking for--
well, if it's there,
then it's running, right?
If it's not there,
then it's not running.
It's a little bit
confusing, right,
because then one level
later we negate it.
So this is-- if it's
running, if I can find it,
then it's running.
So once you have defined
your IdlingResource, then
you need to register it, so that
Espresso knows to actually ask
this particular item
resource, say, hey,
are you idle now,
before it moves on.
Like I said, very
confusing topic, so I've
written a lot about it.
One other thing that I want to
mention, because even I forgot,
is that Espresso only
check the IdlingResource
if it's trying to do a
viewAction, or a viewer
session.
So I have done things
where I am, like, oh,
I registered an
IdlingResource, and then
I'm going to go check
some Java-level thing.
And then it was not actually
waiting for stuff to finish.
Because what happens is
that it inserts itself
in the viewAction and
the viewer session.
So things like
onView, and click,
and matches-- those are
what I'm talking about.
So make sure that you are
"waiting" at those points.
If you think Espresso's
waiting and it's not waiting,
it could be because
that you are not
at the point when it's acting
on the viewAction or a viewer
session.
Good?
OK.
All right.
So now, this is the
point where I think
things get really interesting.
Espresso alone allow you to
click on things and exercise
co-paths, and verify things.
But a lot of times,
as Android developers,
when we want to test, it's more
often architecture problem.
For example, we are going
to go through an example
where your app depends
on the current date.
How am I going to verify things?
It's going to change
every single day.
So Dagger and Mockito
allows you to send out
a test environment that's
predictable and repeatable.
Dagger-- that's dependency
injection-- that's
a fancy term.
All it means is that
in your constructors,
it's going to have
a central repository
to grab objects from.
This way, you can
have one repository
of objects for your app, and
a different one for your test.
Oh, wow.
I just sent what I
wrote on my site.
That's pretty amazing.
And Mockito is what you can
use to provide those objects
in your tests, so
that you can control,
for example, today's date.
So this is the basic
formula for Dagger 2.
Dagger 1 is different.
What we need to
do is, when I say
a repository of objects,
what I'm talking about
is the component.
So here I have
defined the component,
and it knows that it can inject
fields into the mainActivity.
And I have two
different subclauses--
the ApplicationComponent,
which is empty,
meaning that it only
rejects-- it only
injects into the mainActivity.
And there's a
TestComponent, that it
will inject also into the test.
And they are
singletons, because we
want the same object to
be used in app and test,
so that when you
change it in your test,
your app is actually
using that object.
And here, the way you define
what's inside your component
is by these annotations.
So for the application,
we will have
a clock module that will
actually give you today's date.
And in the
TestComponent, we will
provide a mock
ClockModule, so that I can
control what dates get used.
And I have given you also
a beautiful diagram in case
these doesn't make sense, and
what my explanation doesn't
make sense.
OK.
This is just a
graphic representation
of what I just said, right?
So here, I have an
ApplicationComponent
which injects into mainActivity,
and it has a ClockModule that
knows how to provide a clock.
And then in Test,
we have a Mock one,
and it will be injecting into
both the test and the app.
In the application, in
your onCreate function,
we are going to go
ahead and instantiate
one of these
application components.
The reason why it
has such a funky name
is that what you
define the application
components is actually
just an implementation.
Dagger will go ahead and do some
co-generation behind the scenes
and generate this class for you.
Then you can go ahead
and use this class,
and create an
ApplicationComponent
and stash it in this variable.
And then we are
actually also going
to have a setComponent
function, because we're
going to use it in Test.
So what happen is that
when it tests-- actually,
it's probably going to
be in the slide-- just,
you know, maybe I shouldn't
get ahead of myself,
so let me just get
into the next slide.
So here, what we are going
to do is that-- so stash away
what I just said-- the part
that we have an app component
and then we also have
a setComponent function
which is used in Test.
So in Test we are going to
have something different
for the function getNow.
So in the app-- have
you used joda-time?
That's a really nice
date and time library
for Android and for Java.
So DateTime is what the
joda-time will provide you.
If you just give it
with no parameters,
it will give you today's
date and this exact moment.
In the test, what we
are going to do is,
we are going to go to the view
that has the ID date-- this
is actually a TextView.
And then we're going to verify
that it will display the text
2008-09-23.
If you don't use
Mockito and you don't
have control over
the clock, well,
then every day that
you run this test
it's going to display
a different string.
So you can't really test that.
So that's the power of
using Mockito and Dagger.
Dagger allows you to
provide different components
to your app and your
test, and Mockito
allows you to mock the
behavior of that class.
So if you look at it
again, so syntax is, like,
when this function
is called, then
return this particular object.
You don't actually need to write
a function to define things.
They're, like, all
very fluent, and you
can define a lot of
different things in Mockito.
Again, blog post.
Repository.
This one is slightly
different, because I actually
have a course, a video
course that's pre-recorded,
that I actually step through
one particular example.
The example is using
shared preferences.
Because when you think
about shared preferences,
it changes the state of
your application, right?
So maybe first time
you open this app,
someone say that my
favorite animal is cat.
And then the second
time you come
back, you want to
show that it's a cat,
but you don't know whether
it was provided or not.
And you don't want your test
to modify the state of the app.
Right?
Because then it's persisting,
and the next time you run,
you don't know whether
it's going to be
having an initial state or not.
So using Dagger and Mockito, you
can also do things like that.
You can provide an in-memory
shared preferences,
which, every time you run it,
it's going to start from fresh.
[INAUDIBLE] go and delete
your database of the app.
So that is actually a
course that you have to pay,
but since you are all here,
there's a coupon called BABBQ.
If you go there
and you check out,
you can put that
in for a discount.
So in summary, we have
gone through a lot.
Hopefully you still remember,
despite all the drama
of what we learned today,
this is the basic formula
of Espresso, where we have
a Matcher, a ViewAction,
and a ViewAssertion.
With that, you can combine them
to pinpoint a particular view.
We were using the
example of a Toolbar.
And then we actually
used the same example,
but this time write a Custom
Matcher, because we actually
want to use the
toolbar.getTitle function.
After that, we
went through how do
you test something
in the ListView
and the RecyclerView,
which, surprisingly,
is very different,
even though they look
very similar on the surface.
Then I went through
an example with you
on the Idling Resource.
And finally, I think
most applications will
need to go beyond
just using Espresso,
and Dagger and Mockito
are two other libraries
that is often used in
conjunction, so that you
can set up your test environment
and have control over the data.
This is some bonus.
I actually wrote this app and
open sourced it in August.
It uses the nearby API, and
it's completely on GitHub.
You can also download
it on the Play Store,
if you wanted to just
check out what it does.
But I'm going to explain to you.
What it does is that you will
click on that button that says
Google+ sign-in, and you will
sign in, and then you will open
this screen to find Nearby
Devices that also has this app.
And then you exchange
some information.
How on earth are
we gonna test that?
How are we going to
test Google+ log in?
test Nearby Devices?
Well, guess what?
This app has really,
really high test coverage,
because of all the
techniques that I showed you.
I use Dagger and
Mockito, so I actually
have a bridge, what I call.
So instead of calling the
Google API client directly,
I call through the bridge.
So I call onConnect--
onConnect?--
the connect function of my
function through the bridge,
and then I can use
Mockito, so that, oh,
if someone call the
connect function,
then I'm going to capture it,
and then call the onConnected
function and spit it right
out back and run the Callback
for them.
So it's actually
really advanced.
Much more advanced than what
we have gone through before.
But it's completely open,
so go ahead and study it.
And they are also-- beyond that,
we've got Espresso testing.
It also has JUnit
testing, which is
testing on the pure Java level,
mostly on the models, right?
So by model, I mean, in a
Pojo, like a Java object, like,
stores, different
fields in there,
so you can make sure that if you
initialize it this certain way,
it has certain data in it.
And now I also have what I
call UI-less Instrumentation,
meaning that it's
instrumentation in the sense
that you still have contact.
You still have access to your
standard Android libraries.
Where, you know, when you do
JUnit, you cannot do bundle,
you can do all these things.
But there is no UI.
So what I'm using that for is
exercising the database code,
essentially.
So I'm creating a test
database, and then I'm
storing things in
it, and then I'm
calling some function that
will read the database
and then give me some-- I'm
trying not to kick anything--
give me some statistics back.
So that's that
example there as well.
And then, of course, there's
a lot of Espresso going on.
So go ahead and
play with the app.
Again, download it, change
it, and see what it does.
And if you don't
think this is awesome
and you don't trust
my word, I have
someone who said that there are
some seriously badass testing
kung fu on display.
Thank you.
I agree with him,
so-- but you have
to go check it out and see
if you agree that there's
some serious badass
testing kung fu
on display in this repository.
With that, thank you very much.
And these are a lot of
the different resources
that we've covered already.
The first one is the slide deck.
And then the rest
are the example code
that you can find on GitHub.
And also, I actually also
authored video classes
on Pluralsight, which is a
subscription-based service.
You can also check
the [INAUDIBLE]
other things I teach.
And then other places
you can find me
onto the internet-- sorry,
the list is really long.
I have two newsletters, I
have a blog, I have Twitter,
I have Google+.
So plenty of ways to find me.
So one other thing
that I didn't have time
to have slide for is
that a lot of people
tell me that there is so
much effort in doing testing,
like, why would you bother?
So I just want to
give you, like,
one reason why I do it myself.
I work with startups.
And a lot of the times they
will have a server team that
needs to implement
some server change
before I can implement
the Android UI change.
And they are slow.
They're usually slower
than-- well, you know, we
will do a sprint, and
then they'll say, oh,
let's go and implement
that, and I'm
supposed to be implementing
that in that sprint,
and I'm, like, holding my
breath and waiting for them
to implement the server change.
Well, no more.
Because I have Mockito.
I actually use Mock Web Server.
So what I do is
that I have my test,
and all I need to do is agree
on the Java-- not the Java,
the JSON format--
with my server team,
and then I will just
mock out whatever
I expect the response from
the server is going to be.
And I can go ahead and write the
UI code before they are ready.
And I can even test
bad cases, right?
What if I get a 500 error?
Like, what would my app behave?
You don't usually
test a happy path.
And it's really
difficult. How are you
going to do that in
a real life scenario?
Are you going to ask them to
shut down the server so they
can test your 500 case?
No, right?
But in our case, if I have set
up my testing infrastructure,
I have complete control of what
my mock server is going to do,
and I can go ahead and write
my app without the server
ready by "testing."
So "testing" in quotes.
So that's actually
how I use testing.
Which, of course,
then the side benefit
is that it is actually
automatically running, right?
So I can also catch regressions.
So sometimes I will change
one thing in my style,
thinking that will be all
good, but then Espresso
will be, like, yeah,
you said the color is
supposed to be gray, um,
it's actually purple now.
So I can also catch regression
because I have written my test.
So I almost look at
that as a side benefit
of, like, the testing part.
Like, the part I
really like is the fact
that I can mock out
a server, and then I
can go ahead and write my
app without my server team
being ready.
So with that, thank
you very much.
Thank you for tolerating
with my kicking of the sand.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Feel free to leave.
But I can also take some
questions right now.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHIU-KI CHAN: OK.
So the question was, because
of technical difficulty,
we were interrupted
right at the Dagger
point, which is kind of tricky.
So he wants to know how
you can set up Dagger 2.
If you go to my
GitHub repository,
there is a sample project that
is called Android-test-demo.
It uses Dagger 2,
Mockito, and Espresso 2.
And that's a blog
post that's linked
from there, in the written.
So I hope that the blog post
will explain pretty well how,
step-by-step, how you set it up.
Yeah, you can refer to that.
Yes.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
When you discussed the
custom IdlingResource,
I had a question.
It may be due to bad application
design, or something like that,
but it seems like there's a
potential for a race condition
if you're checking for whether
or not a service is running,
and that service has been built
multiple times from the test
client.
Is there a way to have, like,
a named task on the items
resource, so you can see whether
or not the IntentService has
completed its specific
request to fulfill action,
as opposed to whether or
not you want to get general?
CHIU-KI CHAN: OK.
The question was, can I
improve the IdlingResource
for the IntentService,
so instead
of checking whether the whole
IntentService is running,
can I check a specific task?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CHIU-KI CHAN: I don't know
off the top of my head
whether IntentService
is queryable,
if that makes any sense.
I can ask it what it's running.
And it's kind of not really
Espresso-specific, right?
Because it's basically
IntentService-specific.
You're trying to detect
whether your particular task is
running.
So, sorry.
I don't know.
Sorry.
Question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHIU-KI CHAN: So
the question was,
he has a ViewPager that
has multiple RecyclerView
on the different
pages, essentially.
And he will swipe
and said that, OK,
this one is the visible one.
I want to test it,
but differently.
The other [INAUDIBLE]
is still hanging out,
because that's how he
can slide it back in.
And he's asking,
how can I make sure
that I'm verifying the
one that I want to verify.
Right?
Does that sound good?
Give them different IDs?
Does that work?
AUDIENCE: Uh, yeah. [INAUDIBLE].
CHIU-KI CHAN: Oh, I see.
So they're dynamically-- So
they're dynamically attached,
so it's not going to
be using the IDs that
is from the XML file.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHIU-KI CHAN: OK.
He said he uses dynamic tests.
I think that's reasonable.
I mean, I was going to suggest
something similar, right?
You can just issue new
UIDs, essentially, to them,
and then you can verify them.
But that's going to
be random, though.
So if you have something
that's predictable,
then you can go look for them.
So I think you are doing
something quite reasonable.
I mean, there may
be better ways,
but I cannot think
of it right now.
Yeah.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHIU-KI CHAN: So the
question was, get real, now.
How much time did you spend
on writing all your tests?
So it's true.
Like, the set up.
Like, you actually
add some complexity
by using Dagger,
and making it so
that you can mock and whatnot.
I have not clocked the
hours that I'm strictly
writing tests versus when
I'm strictly writing the app,
because the way I
describe I work, right?
I use the test to drive my app.
I will mock out the
server response,
and then go implement
something in a test and run it.
So for me, it's a very integral
part of my development habit,
essentially.
So I can't really tell you
specifically how much time.
But what I can tell you is this.
There are times when it
caught things that I would not
caught on my own.
For example, what I did
was, I did a map fragment
which I was inflating
dynamically, rather than
statically, for some reason.
And when I upgrade from
Google Play Services--
I don't know, 6.5
to 7 or something,
some version-- it broke.
And usually I don't go
to the part of my app
that has the map on it,
because it's kind of not
on the main use case, but my
test caught it right away,
because it crashed.
So I feel like the value
is very hard to quantify.
Like, when I didn't
have the test,
then it would probably be
launched with that crash,
and people will yell at
me from the internet,
and then I have to go find out.
So I don't really have
a hard number for you.
But I find it very--
it's worth doing.
I mean, I think that's
the short answer.
And you have to
check me on that,
because I don't
have data for you.
Cool.
Well, thank you very much.
I'm going to stay
around a bit, so we
can chat off-stage as well.
OK?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]